the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your
scale
how are you guys doing now many of you
will have known that recently there had
been uh some individuals from the
IDF who had put my name alongside other
names on some missiles that they were
going to send to kill some children
because this is the kind of coward
cowardly behavior that permeates the
Zionist and isra pro-israeli movement
this is the cowardliness the the
Cowardly Behavior the Cowardly
temperament the Cowardly disposition of
those individuals So I responded in kind
on X on Twitter and I said that
actually why are you putting my name on
a missile well if you want to get
physical with me if this is meant to be
some kind of intimidation threat then I
open a challenge for
anybody uh from the idea for otherwise
associated with it to legally fight me
in this country in the United Kingdom
and I was responded to by an individual
who I checked and realized potentially
had the best record of MMA of any
Israeli ever and this is quite
surprising let's take a look at what he
said recently in an interview and come
back and respond in kind think about the
pay-per-view all the Muslim World they
want to see him beating me and all the
Jewish World want to see me beating them
so you know it's going to be like a huge
fight it can be it's could be a lot of
money fight you know but I don't know
what he want to fight you know even he
said he want to fight me what boxing
bacle Jiu-Jitsu MMA I don't know so I
said even karate I I can fight him I
don't care I can say you only one thing
if this fight going to happen I would
you I'm going to watch this fight now as
you can see with what he said it seemed
to me that this man his primary concern
is monetary in nature this guy wants
Financial rewards now we said to this
guy in the negotiation we said to him
that we're not going to pay you money
there's videos of you on a tank sending
missiles to Gaza indiscriminately
there's videos of you doing that and you
want us who are doing boycotts and all
this kind of things people like this to
give you money directly effectively
giving money directly to designers and
IDF forces this is something that not
only the community will not find will
find as an unforgivable sin but we
cannot bring ourselves morally or
ethically or otherwise to do it we can't
give money now as a result of that and
some other factors but that seemed to be
as you could see his primary reason and
fact he sent us a message he pulled out
can you imagine this man pulled out now
we already know he can't fight any of
our professionals he can't fight the orl
or this that there's no chance there's
no body in the world that's Pro Zionist
today that can fight any of our top
Muslim Fighters there's no chance
there's no absolutely no way there's no
way and no chance instead he went for
the public
speaker for me you and even then can you
imagine how humiliated him after a
week's
negotiation we we're saying this we're
saying that we're trying to make
accommodate for him this and that he
went for public speaker okay which is me
he went for the public speaker without a
professional record and he started
making demands he wanted to he wanted to
be on cage Rage or one of those programs
who said that this is is going to be it
cannot be sanctioned we checked this
thing it's not going to be sanctioned
anywhere in the west and he wanted the
crowds and all those kind of things we
said there's no in the United Kingdom
they will not allow two crowds and we
checked all this out to be in the same
stadium barely you can allow right a
protest of just prop palestin you have
to get the permission of the police let
alone put both of these people there
will be riots in the crowd so we
explained of the Practical uh
impossibilities that this is
operationally impossible what you're
asking for is operationally impossible
so it has to be a consent agreement and
we have to do it outside of the reach of
the public and yes there will be
professional and all this kind of stuff
and he still backed out we even offered
him a neutral venue outside of the
United Kingdom we even told him we can
fight in Thailand in Bangkok or is it
poet or fuked I don't know how to
pronounce the the word but that's
probably what he said when he heard that
we were going to be fighting him and he
said we'll fight you in anything so I
said fine we fight kickboxing in
Thailand it's easy easy no problem MTI
something like that he rejected he
rejected it can you so this was all fake
it's phony you didn't want to fight
you're a coward that's what you are that
must mean you're a coward you don't want
to fight now that is one of the most
humiliating things somebody in the IDF
putting these names and you're too
scared to fight a public speaker without
a professional record can you imagine
can you imagine what this demonstrates
about the temperament the disposition
the psyche of the pro Zionist in isra
forces can you imagine what he's done to
his community by pulling out like this
and we have all the evidences if if
anyone wants to say anything my manager
Dilly Hussein who's phenomenal manager
fantastic you guys might have known him
from Five Pillars he was communicating
directly with his manager okay and we
went back and forth back and forth and
then even offer us a counter offer he
said
look can we bet can we do this can we do
that we said we don't bet and we're not
going to give this guy money it's not
ethical for us to give this guy money
he's using it for this and for that
reason I didn't promise anybody
money why don't you fight for Honor why
don't you be a man why don't you come
and fight me like a man you said I'll
fight you in anything I explained to you
I want to stand up with you this is what
I want to do with you this doesn't need
to be a Jiu-Jitsu match we know that you
are ADCC accoladed very good it doesn't
need to be let's stand up and fight find
stand up and fight what are you saying I
I'll fight him and do this you're
pretending to want to fight you don't
want to fight because you're over the
hill because you're
retired and you kept talking in that
same video that you kept talking about
my weight and my size bro you're a
professional fighter it's a you can't
even not sanction a fight with someone a
professional fighter with a public
speaker you can't even San it's
unsanctioned in the United Kingdom with
not only a professional fight but a
professional fight with 22 fights un
Bellator it's probably the second
promotion after UFC it's unsanctioned
I'm sorry to say but but you couldn't
even bring yourself to fight me the
public
speaker this is
unbelievable this is
unbelievable you are a shocking coward
what kind of cowardice is this it was
cowardly enough for you to ignore all
the professional fighters and go for the
public speaker all the professional ones
and you go for the public
speaker the public speaker who even in
his region forget about the city even
his we don't rank in the top five or in
his top 10
as a martial art is pound for pound or
anything even not pound for
pound but you backed out of that one as
well you are shocking this is
embarrassing that's it you threw the
towel you threw the white towel before
you even got into the
ring I'm shocked by that but that's the
thing honestly for me it would have been
a win-win situation anyway Allah says in
the
Quran sometimes
Allah he suffices us from having to
fight number one number two the prophet
told
us do not wish to fight the enemy but if
you fight them then be patient I'm not
going to chase you I'm not going to
chase you after this you wasted my time
you wasted my manager's time I'm not
going to chase you after this everyone
cuz this is a public record now what all
your 22 fights mean nothing you know
that all your 22 fights I'm sorry to say
there will be ecli IED by the fact that
you have denied this it's shocking
denial all your 22 fights and your ADCC
and your this and all those competitions
you done in master 10 ibjjf
whatever trust me it's it's going to be
Eclipse no one even watches those fights
just going to remember this is the guy
who backed down from the public
speaker and point number three I was
going to say to you is I was going to
consider this an act of worship
it's always a win-win situation for a
person a Muslim person who does
something
called something which is even like this
fighting all you got to do is change
your mindset and every right hand every
left hook every kick every single punch
and kick that would have thrown on you
it would have been an act of
worship it would have been an act s a
win-win situation so whatever happened
to me in that situation I'm punching you
up and it's like an act of just just
like praying just like fasting punching
you up would have been an act of worship
and that's why it's always a win-win
situation and that's what makes us
different as the
Muslims you can't deal with us how
embarrassing you Scurry along
now you go Scurry along now huh you go
Scurry along now you're done now you're
finished huh throw the white towel and
tell your army to do so as well tell the
IDE of to throw the white to they're
getting destroyed out there they're
getting they're losing the warit they
sign the thing they said they're
losingit you might as well throw the
white towel let them give up and you've
already given
up your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center this Center this Masid this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
more